Das Pockerhof ist hier wieder. Das ist jetzt für dich da.
Das Packard ist für dich da. Das Packard ist für dich da. Das Packard ist schon nicht da. Eher als Co-Gründer, ehemals Co-Moderator, mittlerweile aufgestiegen zu einer Podcast-Legende, möchte ich fast sagen. Ihr wisst natürlich schon, um wen es sich handelt. Es kann nur einer sein. Es ist hier, es ist Stefan. M to the T, Tietze, Tietze, bitte schön, hallo. Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze und du bist Florian Will. Richtig, völlig richtig. Und vielen, vielen Dank für dieses tolle Intro von Uli Versum, den man auch unter dem Künstlernamen Drowned Fish kennt. Der heisst Uli, Leerzeichen, Versum und er hat einen Künstlernamen? Okay. Ja, er hat gesagt, das reicht noch nicht, er ist Drowned Fish und besucht ihn gerne mal auf Spotify. Da gibt es bestimmt noch viele andere Beats und Bytes und Rhythmus, Rhythmen. Manche Menschen brauchen keinen Künstlernamen mehr, finde ich. Nee, Max Power. Uli Versum, finde ich, braucht keinen Künstlernamen. Dass der irgendwo hingeht und dann sagt, mein Name ist so einfältig. Versum Uli, wird er dann genannt. Aber er hat auch kein Ende komponiert. Also hat dann den typischen, die Platte wird langsamer Trick angewandt. Ja. Nicht zu wechseln mit, was ja irgendwie auch alle 80er Songs immer gemacht haben, den Fadeout. Der alte Fade-Out. Und ich stelle mir da immer eine Band vor, die einfach wegfährt, die einfach, die auf so einer, wie man das hat, auf so einer Lkw-Laderampe, die spielt und dann plötzlich einfach wegfährt und man fühlt sich immer so ein bisschen alleingelassen da. Wenn der Song immer leise wird, ich stelle mir immer vor, dass ich als Betrachter weggehe, also dass ich sage, genug Musik für heute, genug Spaß gehabt, ich gehe. Das zeigt unseren Unterschied, weil ich dem VWB, die mich verlassen und wir scheren da in so einem awkward Gespräch und reden noch viel zu laut, die Band gefällt mir gar nicht und dann alle gucken auf mich, weil ich laut zu ihr gesprochen habe, weil die Band wegfährt. Ja, das ist bei dem Pokémon-Album so, diese Pokémon-Rap, Bisa-Flor, Bisa-Sam, Bisa-Flor, Bisa-Sam, Knoss-Flor, dieser Pokémon-ap. Und auf dem Album sind ganz viele Songs drauf, die auch alle ausfaden gegen Ende. Alle faden aus. Ich glaube, die waren ursprünglich mal, das war so eine Art Ringzyklus irgendwie. Jeder Track dauert siebeneinhalb Stunden und der Producer hat gesagt, ach, schneid das nach zweieinhalb Minuten ab hier, dreh den runter den Regler, damit sich das kommerziell besser vermarktet. War vielleicht besser, sonst würde Ash Ketchum heute auf einer Stufe stehen wie Siegfried und
Parzival, aber nein, es wurde kommerzialisiert
als Ash Ketchum.
Beethoven konnte auch keine Enten schreiben,
er gibt einen berühmten Ted-Talk, der heißt
Beethoven kann keine Enten schreiben,
und das merkt man an seiner
fünften, die ja einfach nur eine
Aneinanderreihung von
Bäm, Bäm, Bäm, Bäm, Bäm, Bäm, Bäm, Bäm. Die Leute stehen auf, wollen schon klatschen. Ich war in einer Vorführung, sagt man ja so, einer Vorführung der fünften Symphonie, wo gelacht wurde am Ende, weil das Ende lustig empfunden wurde, weil er halt nicht zum Ende kam. Das ist auch nicht schlecht. Also wenn man, ich finde, Enden können ja ruhig absurd sein. Ja, aber da hat man es zu verlieren, ja. Auch gerade bei so drei Minuten Liedern, die fürs Radio geschrieben wurden, die wurden ja auf diese Länge getrimmt. Da hat man ja noch bestimmt ein paar Ideen rumfliegen gehabt, so, ja komm, dann mach doch einfach hinten, das ist ja einfach ein abruptes Ende, ist eh immer abrupt, dann mach hinten doch irgendwas lustiges. Ja, aber ich mag das, es gibt ja manche Oder wehle ich lauter hinten raus. Es gibt ja manche Tracks, wo hinten am Ende dann nochmal irgendwie so jemand was sagt oder noch so die Musik ausfällt und dann wird noch was gesagt. Das ist nicht ganz, ganz furchtbar, ich will direkt weiter raven, ich bin in der guten Laune, ich sitze im Auto, das ganze Auto wackelt und dann kommt auch zum Beispiel bei Fergie, London Bridge ist es so, wenn du London Bridge auf Spotify hörst, dann hast du den Handy und nein, die Place läuft läuft noch. Der Song läuft halt und der hat einfach zwei Minuten Stille. So ein Roadtrip dann zusammen, du hast die Playlist zusammengestellt, immer wieder zwei Minuten Stille. Ken ist natürlich ein Phänomen, das ganz schmerzlich, jetzt werden wahrscheinlich viele Zuhörer zusammenzucken, alle Fans von Lilla Meyer Landruth natürlich bestens kennen. Die hat ein Album rausgebracht mit all ihren Songs und dann nochmal genauso viele Tracks nochmal, wo der Song anfängt, ausfaded und dann Lena Meyer-Landrut auf dem quietschigsten Stuhl der Welt darüber redet, wie sie diesen Song performt oder geschrieben hat. Und es ist super nervig, weil du immer am Anfang nicht weißt, es ist wirklich so ein Vertrauensbeweis, so ein Bait and Switch, der Song geht los mit ne ne, nene, nene, nene, nene, und dann, ja, also den Song habe ich zusammen mit Lily Allen damals in London, Leder auf Leder, quietscht, Vögel im Zwitschern, das Mikrofon direkt neben dem Scharnier, wo die Lehne an einem Sitzpolster hängt, einfach, da rumsägt, man sich aber auch dachte, ja, schmeiss es auf die Leder.
Nee, man denkt, zu welchem Preis, dafür, dass mir jetzt Lena Maylandhut erzählt, wie sie ihre Songs nicht geschrieben hat? Ich kaufe immer direkt die Deluxe-Version. Egal was es ist. Das ist ein Fehler. Das ist genau dein Fehler. Das ist der Fehler, immer wenn mir jemand sagt, hey, du kannst hier den Film haben oder den Film in der Deluxe-Version mit einem Poster, einem Blechschuber. Ich kaufe immer die Deluxe-Version, die wirklich so viele Millionen Dollar. Mit dem Wendekover. Wendekover, dreh's um, Wendejacken, Wendekover, alles was man wenden kann. Wie viele Wendekover-Blu-rays ich bei mir rumstehen habe, die ich nie gewendet habe, wo die eine Seite immer noch ruft. Wende mich, wende mich! Aber man muss sagen, du hast ein enormes Wendepotential. Also was da, wo du sagst, wenn du jetzt mal sagst, so einen Nachmittag, das ist ja wie so ein Gummiband, das gezogen ist, wenn das Wendecover noch nicht gewendet wurde. Da ist ja eine Spannung drin. Und du kannst einen Tag machen, wo du alle umwendest und dann ist es ja großartig, wenn du das noch vorher hast. Ich finde das super. Das sind auch diese kleinen Aufgaben,
die man sich vornehmen, wenn man Urlaub hat oder kurz mal nichts zu tun hat,
sind das diese kleinen
Tasks, die einen über den Tag bringen,
weil die einem das Gefühl geben,
man hat was geschafft. Heute habe ich
meine Blu-Rays gewendet. Heute alle
wendet. Du willst nicht sterben und die, du willst
nicht im Sterbebett liegen und sagen,
meine Wendekover und dann so
Johnny, versprich mir, dass du meine Cover wendest, dass die FSK noch riesengroß auf dem Gesicht von dem Monsters AG-Typen drauf. Das ist immer noch der beste Sketch der Welt im Internet. Ich weiß leider nicht mehr von wem, so ein englisches Sketch-Kollektiv, reiche ich mal nach. Ein Typ, der bestimmt fünf Minuten einfach nur überall durch seine Wohnung läuft und nachdenkt,
ganz angestrengt, nachdenkt und überlegt und kommt nicht so richtig zu was und will sich Essen machen, kommt nicht dazu, weil er nachdenkt. Es beginnt so und es geht fünf Minuten so und dann sagt er, ah, Bill Paulman. und ich finde es nach wie vor im besten Skate, weil Bill Pullman ist wirklich so jemand, man kommt nicht auf den Namen. Es ist der Präsident aus Independence Day, man hat viele andere tolle Filme gemacht, man kennt ihn, aber man kommt nicht unbedingt auf den Namen. Ich finde, es würde auch mit William Dafoe laufen. Man kennt den, aber es ist auch völlig relatable, dass einem den Namen nicht einfällt. Ja, oder auch hier die Schauspielerin von Billboards Outside Lewin, Missouri. Ebbing, Missouri, ja. Wie die Schauspielerin heißt, jedes Mal, jedes Mal, ich müsste, glaube ich, so ein Bild von ihr in meinen Geldbeutel tun oder so. Ich vergesse es jedes Mal. Oh, ist das deine Frau? Nee, nee, das ist ... Fuck! Gut, dass du ein Bild reingefallen hast. Gut, dass es dir ein Bild reingefallen hast. Ich habe keine Ahnung und ich weiß nicht, viele werden jetzt wahrscheinlich ... Fuck. Hä, sie kennen ihre Frau nicht? Viele werden jetzt wahrscheinlich den Podcast. Wer ist das? Naja, das ist, die hat mitgespielt in, oh mein Gott, mit dem, der, mit dem anderen Typen, der auch in Magnolia gespielt hat, der den Polizisten schon, ach, den hast du auch in Pormonee. 20 Leute, dann so eine komplette Konstellation von Figuren im Gelbäude. Fällt raus. Hast du, hast du ein paar Spickzettel im Gelbäude? Nee, aber ich habe neulich mein Etui gefunden in meinem Jugendzimmer. Etui. Etui. Was ich in Faulenzer war, was ich im über, ihr kennt es nicht? Sagt man zu diesen länglichen, röhrenförmigen Etuis. Faulenzer. Ah, Mäppchen. Ja, sowas. Jedenfalls habe ich das aussortiert, weil das habe ich irgendwie gefunden. Ich habe mein Kindersimmer aufgeräumt über die Weihnachtstage in der Heimat. Und da sind mir ein paar Spickzettel dann doch entgegen geflogen. Ganz kleingeschriebene spanische Vokabeln. Ganz kleingeschrieben, aber auch so. Boco. Und dann, und ich lustigerweise, ich erinnere mich noch an die Wörter, weil irgendwie, natürlich sagt man das auch immer so, aber so ein Spitz-Settel zu schreiben hilft auch einfach, es brennt sich halt so ein, weil es ja schon mit diesem Adrenalin verbunden ist, dass man das vielleicht braucht und so, aber wirklich jeder Quadratmeter des Settels ausgenutzt, um mit ganz kleiner, spitzer Feder zu schreiben. Ich glaube, nie hattest du mehr Handschrift-Skills als in diesem Moment, weil mittlerweile, wenn ich mal was mit der Hand schreiben muss, also absolute Katastrophe. Teilweise mit dem Handrücken liege ich auf dem Blatt Papier, meine Hand stolpert, während sie die einzelnen Sachen versuchen zu schreiben. Was macht die andere Hand, das habe ich mich gefragt. Was macht die andere, während die andere schreibt? Die rudert doch immer so seitlich. Ich hätte mir dann damit geholfen, das festzuhalten, das, worauf ich schreibe. Nee, du musst wie so ein Kö beim Billard die andere Hand so hinlegen, auf der ist dann der Stift. Ich wusste nicht mehr. Ich habe dann auch Weihnachten versucht, so Weihnachtskarten zu schreiben und habe mich dann erst aufgeregt, wie teuer diese Weihnachtskarten sind und dann aufgeregt, dass ich davon sehr viele brauchte, weil ich mich immer verschrieben habe. Ich konnte nicht mehr schreiben. Ich habe einfach vergessen, wie man schreibt. Was nicht passiert natürlich, ist so, dass man, es ist ein anderes Verschreiben als ein Verschreiben natürlich mit dem Laptop oder dem Handy, weil du halt nicht abrutscht oder man ein Wort vergisst oder ein Leerzeichen vergisst oder sowas, sondern du schreibst einfach Unsinn. Auch so ungelernte Fehler, das hat man gar nicht mehr im Kopf.
Ich wollte letztes Mal was aufschreiben und habe irgendwie intuitiv Schreibschrift geschrieben,
bin komplett gegen die Wand gefahren und dachte mir jetzt mal, was denkst du denn eigentlich, wer du bist?
Oh, Herr Professor will, wir schreiben in Schreibschrift.
Denkst du, du bist entweder elf Jahre alt oder Rilke oder was?
Dieses alte Z, was noch so runtergeht, diese Schlaufe und dann so richtig schön ausholen
Vielen Dank. du bist entweder elf Jahre alt oder Rilke oder was. Ja, und dieses alte Z, was noch so runtergeht, diese Schlaufe und dann so richtig schön ausholen und richtig von unten. Hast du auch mit Feder und Tinte geschrieben dann doch. Mit Feder und Tinte. Das Beste ist ja, wenn du das Wort komplett geschrieben hast und dann noch so die I-Punkte, so Punkt, Punkt, Strich, Punkt, Punkt, dann nochmal zurück. Ja, ja, als hättest du nicht am Wortende schon vergessen. Ja, als hättest du nicht am Wortende schon vergessen. Da, da, da, da, da. Ja. Wunder, Mann, und war wirklich Katastrophal. Ich habe mich wirklich geschämt in dem Moment Moment, wo ich dachte, was glaubst du eigentlich, wer du bist? Ja, was glaubst du, wer du bist? Also du glaubst, das kriegst du hin? Also das ist so, wie wenn du dann irgendwie dann zur Buchhaltung gehst und sagst, ja, ich bräuchte das Formular morgen. Und die so, ja, also glaubst du, ich kann das bis morgen einfach so besorgen? Wie soll das glauben? Ja, da muss ich erst den Antrag schreiben, das ans Finanzamt schicken, die müssen es validieren, das kommt nochmal zurück über den Steuerberater und dann kann ich sie kriegen in zwei Wochen. Also wo du denkst so, ja, Entschuldigung. Und dann so mit der Feder ins Tinten fassen und dann ans Finanzamt, aber dann eine schöne Schreibschrift geschrieben. Oh, mit dieser hier, wie heißt es, Legatur oder so, wo das erste, der erste Buchstabe so richtig fancy ist. Das ist auch klassisches Prokrastinieren auf Mönchs Niveau, oder? Wo man sagt, der erste Buchstabe ist so ein riesiges G mit ganz vielen kleinen Figuren drin. Und dann muss man den Satz nochmal umstellen, weil dann ist G nicht mehr am Anfang. Das ist ein Problem. Ne, Schreibschrift fand ich nie so geil dann sehr schnell bin ich dann übergegangen zu, es sind nicht mehr alle Buchstaben miteinander verbunden. Ich finde, Buchstaben müssen nicht alle miteinander verbunden sein. Ne. Es ist auch nicht schneller, Schreibschrift, ich weiß gar nicht, warum man die lernt überhaupt. Und dann irgendwann einen Kuli und dann verschmiert das auch alles so, das ist auch alles eine Scheiße. Das brauchst du auch nicht. Können wir ein bisschen Kinder heutzutage noch Handschrift lernen oder kriegen die einfach irgendwie dann so eine Laserbrille und dann, was die denken, wird dann so eingebrannt aufs Papier. In ihrer Haut. Oder mit so einem Laserdrucker drucken die das mit Gedankenkraft einfach so aufs Blatt Papier. Ich glaube, so läuft das mittlerweile eigentlich. So schön schreiben war auch nie etwas erstrebsames für mich. Weil warum? Also, gut, Schriftbild, aufgeräumt, natürlich befriedet einen das irgendwie von der Art, aber war jetzt nie so etwas, was ich aktiv erfolgt habe. Ich habe immer eher krakelig geschrieben und fand es auch okay. Ja, meine Mutter hat mal meine Handschrift gesehen und hat gesagt, du schreibst sehr klein, Leute, die klein schreiben, haben niedriges Selbstbewusstsein. Haben einen kleinen Penis, hat deine Mutter gesagt. Wir haben gesagt, Leute, die kleinschreiben, haben niedriges Selbstbewusstsein, also schreibt mal grösser. Also das war der Fix zu meinem anscheinend niedergeschmetterten Selbstbewusstsein. Ähnlich viel hätte geholfen, also habt mal ein grösseres Selbstbewusstsein. Beides ähnlich wenig anwendbar. Aber das ist interessant, weil das nennt man noch Graphologie, das Lesen der Handschrift. Und ich glaube nicht, dass es nur Unsinn ist. Ich glaube, da ist viel so Pseudobissenswert. Ich glaube, es ist locker 80 Prozent Unsinn, aber die 20 Prozent, die dann noch übrig bleiben, die sind interessant. Habe ich nicht mehr in meine Graphologie erlebt. Der Enigma, nee, wie hieß der, der Sigma-Mörder wurde nicht auch durch so Handschriftzeug. Es gibt auch eine Reihe von Mördern, die entlarvt wurden, einfach weil sie ja handschriftlich immer dieselben Fehler machen, wo auch der Lehrer sagt, tja, hättest du dir mal mehr Mühe gegeben, hättest du dir mal Mühe gegeben in Handschrift und Schönschrift, wärst du nicht verhaftet worden, Zodiac? Irgendwer hat jetzt in Zodiac einen Brief gelöst von ihm noch einen, super unspannend, das ist halt das Problem. Moment, der kam noch mal einen Brief? Da kamen ganz viele Briefe, die noch nicht gelöst sind, wo noch niemand es hingekriegt hat, die zu dechifrieren. Und jetzt hat irgendwer das hinbekommen, einen der Briefe, auch immer noch nicht alle, aber einen der Briefe zu entschlüsseln. Und es ist halt ein langweiliger, dreckskack, narzisstischer Scheißbrief, wo man denkt, ja gut, it didn't live up. Es hat es nicht geholfen, dass es so lange, der Trommelwirbel war zu lang. Also man hat zu viel erwartet.
Die Handgelenke waren wund, irgendwann es wird nichts.
Ja, ich bin der Mörder und dann eine Adresse
oder Name oder so hat man erwartet. Nein, es war nur
ein, ich bringe dich um im Schlaf und
blablabla, also so basic, basic killer
Stuff. Ich finde mein
Graphologie-Ergebnis gerade nicht, kann
man mit Internet machen. Du hast dich graphologisieren
lassen? Da muss man ein
Goethe-Gedicht schreiben oder sowas ähnliches, irgendwas Goethe-artiges. Schreiben Sie mal ein Goethe-Gedicht. Schreiben Sie mal ein Aussengedächtnis. Welches denn die? Die verarschen einen doch von vorne bis hinten. Muss man aufschreiben und dann muss man zum Beispiel analysieren, wie die Schlaufen aussehen, also ob die von einem G oder von einem kleinen Y oder sowas, unten die Striche, ob die jetzt spitz sind und wie tief sind und generell wie hoch das Triftbild ist, wie tief gedrückt wurde auch, ob das ein fester Druck ist, wie bei mir war es immer ein sehr fester Druck, wohingegen dann immer so, ach, so unselbstbewusste Menschen wie du haben dann immer so klein, faderig, fäserig, faserig, faserig, faserig, faserig, so zu aus gegen Ende auch. Und viele Tränen dann auch auf dem Blatt Papier. Also wir haben jetzt geguckt, sie haben ja sehr viele Tränen auf dem Blatt Papier. Ja, und was bedeutet das? Naja, viel Selbstbewusstsein. Wein mal weniger. Hier kommt dann Blut noch mit rein und hier haben wir sehr viele Kekskrümel auch, also wirklich Oreo, sowohl die weissen Teile als auch die schwarzen.
Oh, wo?
Und dann stand da wirklich ein Text über mich, der, wo ich sagen muss, das stimmt schon.
Aber wie auch bei allen Dingen ist es ein bisschen wie so ein Horoskop, also es passt
auch, man sieht sich da auch gerne drin.
Es war, da stand sehr intelligent, sehr kreativ, gehört auf die Bühne, macht vermutlich einen super erfolgreichen, coolen Podcast, hat eine Netflix-Serie geschrieben, sowas. Das stand da drin. Wow, nicht schlecht. Und ich dachte mir, ja gut, es passt ja auf jeden. Schon schon. Aber hast du das noch irgendwo, das Resultat? Ich glaube, das hast du mir damals auch gezeigt. Wir haben lange darüber diskutiert, ob das nicht Bullshit ist oder nicht mit der Graphologie.
Mach das mal.
Ich finde Graphologen sehr sympathisch, also wirklich einen Menschenschlag, mit dem ich gerne auch mehr Zeit verbringen würde.
Deswegen will ich denen jetzt ungern den Teppich unter den Füssen wegreissen.
Von daher halte ich weiterhin die Fahne gerne aufrecht.
Ich bin da auch käuflich, wenn mir jemand sagt, hey, finde das und das gut, dann finde ich das auch gut.
Ja, geht mal auf graphologies.com, graphologies.com, nee, .de, sorry. Und da könnt ihr dann, einen Textvorlager bekommt ihr dann, Edel sei der Mensch, hilfreich und gut, denn das unterscheidet ihn von allen Wesen, die wir kennen. Am Anfang stand ein Text von Goethe mit freundlichen Grüßen und eine Unterschrift, und dann kannst du anfangen, das zu deuten. Und dann musst du zum Beispiel sagen, ist die Schrift klein, ist sie gross, unregelmäßig, Abstand, wie ist der Zeilenabstand, wie ist der Wortabstand, der Buchstabenabstand und so. Das ist schon ziemlich cool, sehr einfach zu machen, kann man irgendwie mal kurz in fünf Minuten machen. Und vielleicht könnt ihr mal die Ergebnisse vergleichen mit eurem wahren Ich. Hülfreich. Hülfreich. Hülfreich, das ist der feine Herr Goethe. Das ist das Deutsche, I'm in a pickle. Goethe war Hülfreich. Hilfreich. Hülfreich. Das ist der feine Herr Goethe. Das ist das deutsche I'm in a pickle. Goethe war hülfreich. Der kann ja auch schreiben, was er will. Wenn du Goethe bist, wird niemand sagen, das haben sie komplett falsch geschrieben. Ich bin auch kein Goethe-Fan, ehrlich gesagt. Iphigenia auf Taurus, bisschen boring. Also, macht jetzt nichts mit mir. Ich bin jetzt nicht wahnsinnig emotional berührt von den Ereignissen im Ephigenia-Charakter-Zirkus. Aber ich bin ja klar Goethe-Fan, aber eher von seinem Farbzeug. Also das, was er geschrieben hat, naja, so lala. Aber so dieses Farbzeug und die Bilder, die er gemalt hat, das hat mich tief berührt. Was berührt dich, welche Kunst berührt dich so richtig doll? Die frühen Duffy-Duck-Sachen. Die frühen Sachen so ganz am Anfang, wo es wirklich noch starke Spannungsbögen gab und wo man wirklich auch so im Schnabel noch irgendwie wirklich die Struktur gesehen hat, die Emotionen, wo es wirklich ausdrucksstark war. Das war gut, aber dann natürlich mit der großen Lawine in Entenhausen, wo nochmal alles begraben wurde und alles nochmal neu angefangen hat. Das war nichts. Das war nichts. Wo die alle Charaktere umgebracht haben, weil die Schauspieler nicht mehr kommen. Alle Charaktere im Lawinen-Inferno gestorben sind. Das ist einfach unangenehm. Aber wie gesagt, ich meine, die Bibel hat es richtig gemacht, die hat ja auch irgendwie im ersten Akt super viele strange Sachen eingeführt mit Riesen und Engeln und so und dann einfach gesagt, Leute, wir kommen hier nicht mehr voran, da sind so viele Storylines, da gibt es noch irgendwie diesen einen Typen, der in Palermo irgendwie eine Bäckerei aufgemacht hat, die Storyline, die führt zu nichts mehr, wir schneiden ständig zu dem Typen hin, der macht nichts mehr, der sagt auch, Leute, ich habe nichts mehr, er guckt in die Kamera, quasi, Ich habe hier nichts mehr. Wir schneiden ständig zu dem Typen hin, der macht nichts mehr, der sagt auch, Leute, ich hab nichts mehr.
Er guckt in die Kamera, quasi.
Ich hab hier nichts mehr zu bieten.
Wie wär's denn? Meine Idee,
ich hau mal was raus.
Riesige Flut.
Alles weg,
bis auf einen. Und der
fängt dann aber von vorne an. Und dann ist dieser ganze
Zwergquatsch, diese
ganzen kleinen Grollme, die irgendwie sechs Arme haben. Die Golems, die Gorbs, die Schlupis, alle weg. Die Gorbs, die irgendwie vier verschiedene Geschlechter haben. Das ist ultra weird. Also ich weiß nicht, was wir da uns eingedacht haben. Ja, wo soll denn das ganze Wasser herkommen? Und dann wollte der Bay-Rider schon wieder anfangen mit seinen Wassermonstern und dem Element Wasser, was gegen Feuer gewonnen hat.
Was ist mit den Elementasten, überleben die nicht im Wasser? So. Und weißt du was, das war es jetzt auch mal mit dir. Nein, nein, nein, du bist jetzt hier auch mal, das war es jetzt, ich habe keine Lust. Ich weiss, dein Vater hatte damals diese ganze Stube hier aufgemacht, unsere Schreibstube, so, aber du schlaberst, du schreibst Kacke. Die Elementasten führen nirgendwo hin. Deine Palermo-Storyline geht mir sowas von auf die Nerven. Ja, da habe ich mich ein bisschen verrannt. Ich dachte, wenn du so einen Pizzabäcker irgendwie hast, der versuchst auf eigene Faust. Das war spannend. Man fragt sich erst warum, es war aber dann auch auf eine Art, irgendwie gebe ich auch selber offen zu, ganz cool und unterhaltsam.
Dann fragt man sich aber, Moment, aber das ist ja die Bibel, die ging in ganz andere, große Zusammenhänge, warum der Pizzabäcker aus Palermo?
Ja, es tut mir leid, das war Quatsch, war nix, sorry.
Aber apropos Bibel zum Thema, ich glaube, wir haben letztens mal auch über Beyblade gesprochen, zum Thema Beyblade-Plotstruktur haben wir analysiert, wie ist der erste Akt, zweite Akt und sowas, wie sieht es aus? Wir sind in die Details gegangen, welche, was sind die Lieblings-Beyblades, Top 5 Lieblings-Beyblades, Top 5 Lieblingsfolgen-Beyblade. Genau, und jetzt habe ich erfahren, dass tatsächlich, weil die Frage ist natürlich, was zur Hölle passiert in der Folge Beyblade? Also klar, die drehen sich schwer zu zeichnen.
Und gibt es da ein Match oder fünf Matches oder ein Turnier in einer Folge?
Und da hat mir jemand einen Clip zugeschickt von aus einer Folge Beyblade.
Und zwar ist es tatsächlich nach der Beyblade-Lore so, dass Mose mit einem Beyblade das Meer geteilt hat.
Mose hat mit einem Beyblade das Meer geteilt. Also Mose hat mit einem Beyblade das Meer geteilt.
Also man fragt sich ja, wie ist das eine Folge Beyblade? Nein, wie ist das? Nee, das ist nur so ein Flashback so. Du erinnerst dich doch sicher noch, als Mose oder Moses, also auch nicht genau, Plural, ein Mose, zwei Mose, zwei Mose, hat mit einem Beyblade das Meer geteilt. Und also finde ich auch gut, dass diese so genreübergreifend auch da reingehen und sagen, vielleicht gibt es ja Plotlücken von anderen Universen, die wir lösen können mit unseren Beyblades. Weil wir haben diese Beyblades, lass uns machen. Und Triceratopse haben auch mit Beyblades ihre Revierkämpfe ausgetragen, richtig? Genau, wie sind die ausgestorben? Ein großer Beyblade ist dann doch auf die die Erde gefallen. Die alle weggebladed so. Aber das finde ich auch ganz gut, dass auch die Schreiber von Beyblade sich nicht so schade waren zu sagen. Was können wir machen, was können wir machen? Von Mose, oder? Mose? Joa. Bei unserer Kinderserie einfach schon mal Moses Beybladed einfach irgendwie. M Moses und Jesu. Es ist so merkwürdig. Es war ein bisschen egal. Es ist auch alles egal. Also klar, um mal wieder bei deinem Lieblingsthema zu sein, um jetzt nochmal dieses Highbrow-Segment nochmal, dass ich da auch was dazu sagen kann, auch mal ein paar Nachnamen sagen kann. Wagner, der auch in seinem Ring, in seinem berühmten Ring, ja auch Loge auftreten lässt. Und wo man sich auch fragt, was zur Hölle soll denn Loge sein? Der lügt. Weil der heißt ja Loki und später hat er auch den Namen geändert wieder in Loki, hat aber sich gedacht, wie heißt der? Ach, bevor ich in dem Buch nachschaue, der wird schon irgendwas mit L heißen. Ja, nee, Loge. Die singen auch Loge, obwohl das einfach auf dem Schreibfehler ist, einfach falsch. Nee, der hat den Loge genannt. Nee, aber der hat sich später revidiert, der hat später gesagt, nee, das... Hat er sich vertan? Irgendwann später, glaube ich, auch in dem selben Stück oder in anderen Opern, sagt er dann doch, ja, nee, ihr habt schon recht. Loki. Nachdem da irgendwie hunderte Fan-Mails kamen und so. Aber selbst da halt nicht so... Ja, aber damals zu seiner Verteidigung, man konnte es auch nicht so gut nachhalten. Also jetzt solltest du halt... Nee, da kann er auch Nietzsche fragen. Machst du Command-F und guckst kurz nach, wie du den vorher genannt hast in Akt 1. Ja. So, oder Final Draft, zeig dir schon an, wie die deine Figuren heissen. Ja, und was als nächstes passieren soll. Und was als nächstes passieren soll. Und was als nächstes im Idealfall passiert. Wohingegen damals konnte er das nicht machen. Dann weiß er, irgendwas war das mit L. Ja, stimmt schon. Lurch. Aber da gibt es halt auch nicht so etwas wie jetzt heute diesen Star Wars Council, die ein Auge drauf haben, dass das plotmäßig alles zusammenpasst. Dass die Welt stimmig ist. Und dass die Figuren nicht einfach plötzlich Namen wechseln und einfach plötzlich irgendwie Ice Cream, McIce Cream heißen, sondern so, nee, nee, der hieß Luke Skywalker. Ach so, dann schreibe ich es nochmal um. Aber Respekt, ehrlich gesagt, das haben die damals schon alle ganz gut hinbekommen. Da wir so richtig große Geschichten geschrieben haben, auch so Tolkien, dass er sich nicht irgendwie am Ende nochmal verschrieben hat oder vertan hat. Ich meine, entweder er ist ein Genie oder die Leute haben es wirklich komplett gelesen und konzentriert und gesagt, wenn du da diese Regler aufgemacht hast für die Welt, dann hast du sie da nicht zu brechen. Oder er hat es selber hingekriegt. Aber ich würde mich konfirmierlich. Er hat sich mit dem Auenlandkampf vertan. Also wie gesagt, Tolkien Genie und so, aber dass sie dann nochmal gegen Saruman im Auenland kämpfen, ist für mich ein Fehler. Zum Glück im Film nicht vertreten, aber ist für mich ein Patzer, ein Riesenpatzer. Du bist nicht drüber hinwegge, ne? Riesenfehltritt, bin nicht darüber weggekommen. Das Jahr 2020 war für dich ein grosses, war einfach furchtbar, ein grosses Desaster, weil du vor allem herausgefunden hast, dass im Outland noch gekämpft wurde. Ne, das war nichts, das war nichts. Bis jetzt auch keine Entschuldigung bekommen, dass es nochmal zurückgezogen wird, das hat einfach nicht funktioniert in meinen Augen. Aber gut, dass sich Beyblade dann entschieden hat, die christliche Kultur aufzugreifen. Ja, absolut. Oder jüdisch? Es muss es... Naja, ist es nicht so alles unter Abraham, ist es nicht alles ähnlich. Ähnlich, aber das fand ich schon interessant. Er hätte ja auch einfach sagen können, Ramses halt mit dem Beyblade. Ja, ich glaube, da hat Yu-Gi-Oh schon alle Rechte gekauft. Stimmt, Yu-Gi-OhOh! hat sich komplett auf die ägyptische Kultur. Ägyptensachen drin, wo auch einfach cool sein, dass diese ägyptische Sachen, die ja so ein bisschen angestaubt waren, zu sagen, wir machen das nochmal cool durch Yu-Gi-Oh! Und dann finden alle Leute, da gab es bestimmten Hype, irgend so ein ägyptisches Museum hatte da einen bestimmten Hype durch Yu-Gi-Oh!, dass sich alle nochmal die Opo-Lypen
und die Karof-Lypen nochmal angeguckt haben.
Die Stalagmieten, die Stalagmieten
alles nochmal angeguckt haben, einfach weil es
einen Yu-Gi-Oh!-Hype gab. Ja, ich glaube auch.
Aber da auch eine gute Frage,
ist ein Match,
ein Yu-Gi-Oh!-Duell, sorry,
ist ein Yu-Gi-Oh!-Duell eine Folge
und mehrere Folgen?
Mehrere Folgen. Oder passiert sogar
mehrere, passieren mehrere Duellen in einer Folge?
Nein, will ich mehrere Folgen
Vielen Dank. Jog-I-Oh-Duell eine Folge und mehrere Folgen oder passiert sogar mehrere Duell in einer Folge? Nein, wirklich mehrere Folgen drehen sich um ein einziges Du-Du-Du-Du-Duell. Das ist schon genial eigentlich. Genial, also die Autoren, die müssen es wirklich einfach geschafft haben. Die können ja jetzt alle schreiben. Ich glaube, wenn du wirklich so die Jog-I-Oh-Story wirklich plottrelevanten Teil zusammenschneidest, kannst du dir 14 Staffeln in 30 Minuten erzählen.
Was da wirklich passiert zwischen, er wartet ewig, bis er die Karte gezogen hat.
Aber das war schon emotional, Seto Kaiba und sein Bruder, das war schon, wie heißt der nochmal?
Ich weiß auch nicht mehr, Mose. Ich habe alles vermischt in meinem Kopf, es ist einfach ein grosses Bash-up, einfach nur noch alles zusammenwerfen. Werbung. Heute haben wir was ganz Besonderes für euch. Koro ist Europas Nummer eins Anbieter für haltbare Lebensmittel. Es ist unglaublich. Was die für ein Sortiment haben, schaut mal vorbei auf korodrogerie.de. Allein die Snacks, die habe ich mir natürlich angeguckt. Es gibt verschiedene getrocknete Bohnen, getrocknete Früchte, es gibt ein Bohnen-Mix, Chili-Limette, geröstete Maiskörner mit Salz, Süsskartoffelchips, alles gesund und fantastisch hochwertig produziert. Genau, alles Bio, alles tolle Qualität, faire Preise und man spart da Verpackungsmüll durch grosse Verpackungen. Ja, es ist wahnsinnig viel und es ist gut. Also wie soll es noch besser sein? Wir hatten am Set von Staffel drei, hatten wir einen riesigen Sack mit getrottenen Erdbeeren und die waren so lecker und einen hatten wir mit getrotten Himbeeren. Und es ist natürlich wahnsinnig gesund, ein toller Snack für zwischendurch, aber auch sehr lustig, weil es so ein riesengroßer Sack war, wo das ganze Team von essen konnte. Total lecker, gibt es sehr viel Auswahl, über 700 Produkte, Superfood, Snacks, Trockenfrüchte, Nussmuse, Riegel, Bars, alles. Schaut euch da einfach mal um, da ist für jeden was dabei auf korodrogerie.de. Und wenn ihr den Gutscheincode UFO benutzt, dann bekommt ihr sogar 5% Rabatt auf alle Artikel. Also guckt euch mal um, da ist bestimmt für jeden was dabei. Und dann könnt ihr gerne knabbern, aber nicht zu laut knabbern, sonst hört ihr den Podcast nicht mehr. Korodrogerie.de und das ist das Podcast UFO. Viel Spaß. Werbung. Warum nicht einfach mal so einen riesen Crossover-Film machen? Das sagte ich mir bei Marvel's Avengers ja auch schon, wenn da jetzt noch Bisasam rumgehüpft wäre. Nee, einfach gerne noch ein Film mit allen drin, irgendwie Jerry Seinfeld ist dabei und dann kommt da halt Superman und irgendwie Donald Duck ist dabei. Ich fände das mega. Yu-Gi-Oh! kämpft mit Bidasam gegen Jerry Seinfeld.
Fände ich jetzt schon mal super.
Ja.
Dann kommt noch Captain America.
Und Sattelka-Hilber sagt Nein.
Jack Sparrow, Captain Tsubasa, alle einfach zusammen.
Und George Costanza sagt, was ist denn hier los?
Und dann kommt Larry David an und sagt, hä? Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da. Es ist grossartig. Einfach alles zusammenwerfen. Lass mal die Grenzen sprengen zwischen den IPs. Wenn ich richtig viel Geld hätte, ich glaube, ich würde mir primär so IPs kaufen, so Lizenzen an Sachen und dann einfach Leuten geben, Autoren geben. Ja, Autoren geben, so schreib alles zusammen, schreib mir Crossover, schreib dies, schreib das und ich würde es einfach alles selber produzieren. Einfach gucken, wie weit kann man es treiben, bis jemand sagt jetzt Stopp, jetzt reicht es, einfach wirklich das Ganze an Maximum umbringen.
Wenn du einen Crossover-Film Hollywood-Blockbuster schreiben könntest, aus zwei IPs, was würdest du machen? Was wäre das coolste Crossover?
Oh, das ist schwierig. Ich glaube, das hatten wir sogar mal als Filmfallsfrage.
Blockbuster.
Da habe ich sehr, sehr viel Kritik geerntet, weil da war ich Judge, da war ich anscheinend sehr inkompetent.
Ich stehe heute noch zu meiner Entscheidung, aber es ist ein anderes Thema. Aber ansonsten, naja, ich glaube schon sowas wie Gute Zeiten, Schlechte Zeiten und Dresaurier oder was. Ja, genau. Ich glaube schon sowas. Wie so eine biedere Sitcom. Mit Charakteren, die aus den kleinsten Problemen die grössten Sachen machen.
Weil ich meine, für gute Zeiten, schlechten Zeiten Charaktere ist ja schon, der und der hat die und die geküsst. Das Schlimmste, was passieren kann. Wenn jetzt, ich will wissen, was passiert, wenn so ein schöner Velociraptor bei denen auf der Fussmatte steht. So, Freunde, das Leben beginnt und Godzilla. So, das ist ein Mashup, das würde ich mir anschauen. Die müssen ja Abi machen und irgendwie wer mit wem und wer hat ein Bombenalarm ausgelöst, aber halt auch Godzilla als B-Story immer dazugeschnitten, wie Godzilla gerade im Sicht. Als langweiligere B-Story. Ja, das finde ich gut. Das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Was würdest du mischen? Gute Frage. Ich glaube, ich würde mischen. So, und jetzt muss man sich gut
überlegen, was man sagt.
Ich meine einmal Mini-Playback-Show,
Mini-Playback-Show
meets das Boot. Oder halt so was,
wirklich so zwei deutsche Klassiker,
wo du ungefähr von der Zielgruppe ähnlich
bist und dann einfach mal schauen,
wie es läuft. Oh, Contagion
und das Boot finde ich nicht so schlecht.
Ja, finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Wahrscheinlich gibt es da irgend so eine KI, die das machen kann, denen du zwei Skripts geben kannst und da sagst, mach mir einen Mashup einfach daraus. Das finde ich nicht schlecht. Gibt es auch bestimmt, oder? So KIs, die man trainieren kann, die man dann unterschiedliche Skripts geben kann und dann produzieren die so eins. Ich war ja echt enttäuscht für den Pokémon-Film. mir pokémon das ist auf jeden fall eine gute ip die man vielleicht nutzen sollte hier pokémon und jurassic park ja das jemand hat wirklich einfach pokémons kreiert ja und da kann man in diesen park fahren und am ende läuft dann dieser den riesen tourtalk rum und bringt alle um ich weiß auch nicht ob das beste für die ip der detective ip kats der da rumgehopst. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob das die richtige Idee war, dass du da direkt einen Crossoff machst, direkt Detective. Du machst ja auch nicht dann direkt irgendwie Leichtathlet Pikachu oder sowas. Das ist ja Benjamin Blümchen-Fehler. Du brauchst auch du kannst nicht direkt anfangen mit Benjamin Blümchen als Hirte oder so. Du brauchst erst mal straight, wer zur Hölle ist Benjamin Blümchen?chen? Who the fuck is Benjamin Blümchen eigentlich? Das ist Folge eins. Was will Benjamin? Was will er? Was will er? Das ist Folge eins. Und dann, wenn die Leute mal gecheckt haben, okay, so ist der drauf, dann kannst du sagen, Benjamin Blümchen als Atomkraftwerk Sicherheitswart. So, dann geht's los. Aber du musst den erstmal kennenlernen. Hüsterich und Schlieferinchen haben wir ja auch in den ersten Runden. Hüsterich und Schieferinchen und Godzilla war nicht das erste, beste Buch. Da haben wir dann gesagt, komm, nee, wir machen nochmal erstmal. Nee, wir hatten da vorne eine komplette Staffel, Was wollen Sie? Wo die wirklich mal erklärt haben, Was wollen Sie? Wo die wirklich mal gesagt haben, meine Charaktermotivation ist folgende, ich würde gerne alle Kinder krank machen. Gut, da haben wir jetzt viel Kritik geändert, auch dann so von Kinderbuchzeichnern, weil die meinten, das wäre langweilig für Kinder, weil es einfach nur von einem schwarzen Hintergrund die beiden Charaktere sind, die ins Auge des Betrachters einfach kurz vorstellen, ganz trocken, mit so gefalteten Händen, schön trocken, einfach lange Sprechblasen, wo sehr viel Text drin ist. Teilweise Sprechblasen, die über mehrere Seiten gehen. Also wirklich, das sehen die Kinder auch wirklich nicht gerne. Aber gut, dafür haben wir das abgehandelt. Und dann zweites Buch. Zweites Buch, Hysterich und Schnieferinchen gegen das Boot oder irgendwie sowas. Oh, das wäre geil, Hysterich, Schnieferinchen und Mini-Playback-Show, die machen alle Kinder krank, kann die Sendung noch stattfinden? Was macht Rameike Amado? Die Rechte waren ein bisschen schwierig. Kevin ist trotzdem allein zu Hause in Amerika. Ja, das ist klar, der macht gar nichts. Der macht sein Ding. Langweilig ist ein Crossover ever. Das ist einfach ab und zu der Film untergeschnitten. Ja, ja, das ist ja auch so wie bei zum Beispiel Hell der Ringe, wo die ständig zwischen den verschiedenen Sachen hin und herschneiden, die nichts miteinander zu tun haben. Aber da hätte ich mal eine Frage. Könnte man, weil viele Filme spielen in Atlanta, viele Filme spielen in New York. Kann man nicht theoretisch das so machen, dass man Filme verbindet und die wie bei Herr der Ringe zusammenschneidet zu einem Film? Die so nebeneinander laufen. Die so nebeneinander laufen. Oder so über Kreuz, die sich einmal in der Mitte treffen. Welche Filme würden laufen?
Ich dachte doch mal, Annie Hall. Annie Hall und
Spider-Man. Und Spider-Man ist auch in New York.
Und dann sieht man ab und zu
im normalen Raum, Annie Hall,
zwei Leute reden miteinander, wo die Ellen
und irgendwer und im Hintergrund
und beide so, beide
ignorieren es.
Ja, haben wir erfolglos versucht mit dem Power Ranger in unserem Bibelsketch mit Jesus und den Power Rangers. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Leute das so gut aufgenommen haben. Das hat zu viel Irritation geführt. Aber klar, die müssen ja auch irgendwann angefangen haben. Es ist ja unrealistisch, dass du nie andere Figuren siehst, wenn du da im Nahen Osten unterwegs bist. Damals, da müssen ja ganz viele Sachen angefangen haben. Da waren dann die Simpsons, hatten dann ihre Leute, die hatten die Leute, die Schlümpfe, da gibt es bestimmt auch so eine Jesus-Story, dass die sich halt nie begegnen, ist unrealistisch, deswegen führ die einfach mal zusammen. Führ zusammen, was zusammen gehört. Ja. So, geht raus, verbreite die Kunde und haut mal was raus, schreibt mal irgendwie so eine kleine Kurzgeschichte, so ein unerhörtes Ereignis, eine Kurzgeschichte, einen kleinen Limmerick oder sowas. Schreibt mal eine Crossover-Kurzgeschichte. Ja, finde ich gut. Aber kurz, wirklich kurz und knagelig. Nee, kurz, ich betone nicht auf Kurzgeschichte. Ja, wirklich auf, also wirklich eine sehr Kurzgeschichte. Wir sind ein Teil von Lehrern, die immer sagen, ja, nee, schon fünf Seiten, wir sind so, nee, komm, halbe Seite, maximal, maximal. Ja, und dann immer so die, sich die Blätter kaufen, die den größten Zeilenabstand haben. Und du denkst, komm ich damit durch, das sind drei Zeilen pro Seite, komm ich damit durch, funktioniert das? Ist das genial? Ja, Cheaterblätter. Habe ich noch nie gehört. Kann man das nicht verkaufen? Natürlich. Die heißen das Podcast-Ufo. Das sind Blätter. Das ist eine gute Idee. Das sind Blätter mit einem leicht grösseren
Zeitenabstand. Man, jetzt muss ich schon, ich habe
noch eine ganze Seite frei. Was soll
ich schreiben? Moment mal, du kennst
nicht das Podcast Ufo.
Du kannst zu dir
Blätter bestellen, die haben grösseren
Zeitenabstand. Da werden aus vier
Seiten ganz schnell
fünfeinhalb. Was?
Weil der Zeitenabstand leicht
grösser ist. Leicht grösser ist. Nee, aber das finde ich
genial. Und die sind kleiner.
Die Seiten ganz schnell fünfeinhalb. Was? Weil der Zeilenabstand leicht grösser ist. Leicht grösser ist. Nee, aber das finde ich genial. Und die sind kleiner. Die sind nicht Diener vier, sondern die sind Diener fünf. Aber es fällt einem erst auf, wenn man die direkt nebeneinander legt. Ich finde das genial. Ja, stimmt schon. Was Lehrer nicht tun. Die haben ja einen ganzen Stapel, das fällt schon auf. Nein, nein, nein, ich glaube nicht, dass es auffällt. Wenn die leicht kleiner sind. Ja, was heißt leicht kleiner? Weil niemand stellt auch in Frage, oh, die hat diese Tieterblätter gekauft. Das würde niemandem, kein Lehrer würde sagen, oh, der will weniger schreiben, deswegen hat er sich ein leicht kleineres Blatt geholt. Ja, ist eine geniale Idee. Ich glaube, es rechnet sich nicht bei eurem ersten Aufsatz, aber über so eine ganze Schullaufbahn, glaube ich, rechnet sich das wirklich. Hast du locker zwei, drei Stunden mehr Freizeit, um irgendwie einen Ball gegen Wand zu dazuen? Einen Ball gegen das Garagentor zu schmeißen. Sowas, was Kinder machen in ihrer schönsten Zeit des Lebens. Ja, Bayblade in der Arena. Ich hatte eine Bayblade-Arena tatsächlich damals. Ich hatte eine kleine Plastik-Arena und Bayblade. Da konnte man sich die zusammenschrauben, wieder anders konfigurieren und dann gegen Freunde schön gebaybladet. Aber es ist halt im Endeffekt so ein Kreisel. Und nach zehn Sekunden kippt eins um und der andere siegt. Und auch als Kind ist man nicht so wirklich, man hat so nicht so eine Beziehung zu seinem Kreisel. Man fühlt sich nicht so wie Moses, der das mehrteilt. Das kommt nicht rüber. Aber wir haben uns tatsächlich damals Baby-Blades selber gebaut, aus Lego. So aus Lego-Technik haben wir uns selber Baby-Blades gebaut. Und das hatte dann nochmal einen ganz anderen Flair, wie diese Roboter-Show, wo die Leute Roboter bauen, die gegeneinander kämpfen, ferngesteuert mit der großen Axt und dem großen Feuerflammenwerfer und sowas. Das war eine richtig gute Show. Robo-Wars sind so geil. Das wäre auch mal ein geiles Crossover. So Robo-Wars meets irgendwie Shopping-Queen. Du fährst, die Dinger brechen aus und fahren irgendwie dann in so einen Shopping-Laden rein und zerhacken dann da die Einkäufer. Das fände ich auch nicht schlecht. Kann Rocket Beans nicht mal ein Robo-War veranstalten? Also welches Turnier mit Robotern, die halt so Teams, Zweierteams, du und weiss nicht, Ilyas. Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee. Es hat, glaube ich, recht aufwendig, so etwas zu bauen, oder? Roboter. Da ist es auch wahnsinnig Spaß zu gucken. Gut, da muss man jetzt schauen, ist es das eigentlich mehr viel Arbeit gegen wahnsinnig Spaß. Lohnt sich das oder macht man nicht lieber was, was wenig Aufwand ist, mit Medium-Spaß, mit so Mittel-Öhrers, zum Nebenherlaufen. Aber Robot Wars, ich habe mir nicht gemerkt, was am coolsten ist. Es gibt diese Insektenkriege, so Turniere, wo, das ist aber martialisch und auch, glaube ich, verboten, aber gibt es in Japan so Seiten. Nein, es gibt niemanden, der auf der Seite der Insekten ist. Wo man dann verschiedene Insekten in Turnierformen gegeneinander antreten lässt. Wo immer der, habe ich mir gemerkt, dieser Ahornkäfer gewinnt, der mit dem grossen Geweih, dieser Hirschkäfer, die immer zerberstet, weil er diese unfassbare Kneifkraft hat, da hat niemand eine Chance so richtig. Aber es waren so hochgiftige Spinnen, keine Ahnung. Aber ich habe mir nicht gemerkt, dass der bei Robo Wars immer gewinnt. War es die Axt? Der hat den auf den Rücken gelegt. Die Flipper, ne? Die Flipper, aber da glaube ich wurden ja auch gekontert mit jemandem, der vorne und hinten fahren kann. Also was nicht gewinnt, meines Erachtens sind Äxte. Weil Äxte, die machen schon Schaden, aber halt so sehr punktuell und es ist meistens egal. Der Roboter ist ja nicht mehr so schön, aber ey, du gewinnst nicht mit einer Axt. Du gewinnst auch nicht mit einem Flammenwerfer. Aber cool, cooles Faktor gewinnst du. Ich weiß auch nicht, wer am besten war bei dieser Knetshow, wo diese Knetfiguren gegeneinander gekämpft haben, wer da am besten war. Man hat lieber Grosskneten oder Kleinwennigkneten, ich weiss auch nicht. Was in der kleinen Halle neben dem Robo-Wars stattfindet immer. Immer ein bisschen weniger Zuschauer. Ja, das ist so der Battle District in so einer Stadt. Und es ist ganz leise und aus der Nebenhalle hört man immer Yey, yey und Äxte.
Und der Knetkampf, nur so, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf, pf so ach, wir wollen nicht, pst, vielleicht, also ich würde mal rüber gucken. Nee, wir haben jetzt gesagt, Knete, außerdem gab es keine Tickets mehr. Ach ja, Kampf, oder? Zwei gehen rein, einer geht raus, martialisch, wer ist der Bessere, einer stirbt, wie weit bist du bereit zu gehen, das ist faszinierend, das ist toll. Aber man muss sagen, man hat die Gladiatorenkämpfe nicht mehr hinbekommen, also man hat das nicht mehr, weil maximal viele Stakes, so heutzutage muss man sich dann irgendwie, muss man wetten, damit man noch mitfiebert und sowas. Damals ging es halt auch um Leben, also das ist ja, da hat man schon sehr früh so Top of the Game erreicht. Ich glaube, was Unterhaltung anbietet, waren wir als Menschheit schon mal woanders.
Vielleicht die erste Staffel Two Detectives.
Aber ansonsten, glaube ich, waren wir nie wieder auf dem Niveau von Gladiatoren.
Weil Gladiatoren, da geht es halt richtig um was.
Das ist so, oh, der hat jetzt die Chance, Schachweltmeister zu werden.
Okay, aber der muss gewinnen, sonst stirbt er, ist halt nochmal eine andere Hausnummer. Deswegen glaube ich, lass wieder dahin zurück. Stell dir vor, du bist irgendwie so ein Lyra-Spieler im alten Rom und hast seine Lyra und musst konkurrieren gegen zwei Leute kämpfen auf dem Tod. Und du sagst, Leute, ich meine, ich kann gut Lyra spielen, kein Stress, ich kriege die Hits hin, irgendwie Cäsar, Cäsar. Die grossen Hits, Cäsar, Cäsar, Cäsar. Die grossen Hits. Cäsar, du hast es oft nicht leicht. Cäsar, solche Sachen, der Rubikon, ja, Rubi, Rubi, Rubi, Rubikon, Rubikon.
So, das sind so die Klassiker, die ich alle auf der Lyra kann.
Aber nebenan kämpfen halt einfach zwei Leute gegen den fucking Löwen.
Und du da... Brrring, prrong, brrring, prrong, prrong, prrong, prrong, du hast es auf mich.
Und jemand steht auf mit so einer wackelnden flachen Hand so, ne, ich schau mir lieber die Löwen an.
Und dann mit der Lyra dem Löwen zum Fast vorgeworfen. Und dann so ein Theaterstück. Ja, da haben wir wieder. Ich gehe nicht auf Taurus. Das hat nicht so Einschlagskraft. Nee, ich finde auch, lass wieder dahin zurück, weil alles andere ist ein bisschen noch albern.
Also seitdem, ich weiss nicht, es geht halt um nichts.
Wer schiesst die meisten Tore, Barcelona oder Bayern München?
Wer hebt irgendwie, wer kommt da rüber über die Stange?
Über die Stange, wer springt weiter?
Schafft das, ja.
Nö, geht das, was passiert, nö.
Wirft den Speer.
Und er kann es, im schlimmsten Fall, ja, dann muss er es nächstes Jahr nochmal probieren. Die Weltmeisterschaft wird nächstes Jahr wieder starten. Sehen wir ihn dann das ganze Jahr oder nicht? Nö. Ach so, okay. Dann kommt er nächstes Jahr wieder. Aber ist das sein Job oder ist es... Das ist auch so beim, ich habe auch wieder über Weihnachten viel so Bob und Schlitten geguckt und so. So, und, ich finde es immer erstaunlich, wie schlingt Tom Bartels und so, was jetzt die ganzen Kommentatoren von ARD und ZDF, wie die es hinbekommen, da so eine Euphorie aufrechtzuerhalten. Weil gerade bei Schlitten denke ich mir, ja, dann ist der Hals schneller. Ist ja nicht so, dass es eine große Leistung war. Naja, das ist, das ist glaube ich, also da kommst du wiederst du wieder mit deinem Ranz an. Ich glaube, dass du dich da so leicht nach rechts und nach links lehnst, das ist schon auch anspruchsvoll. Tatsächlich, wer war die erste berühmte Person, die du live gesehen hast? Ich kann die Frage dir gerne beantworten, während du noch dümmlich nachdenkend in die Ecke guckst. Und zwar war es bei mir der Hackerl Schorsch, und zwar Goldmedaille gewonnen im Schlittenberg runterfahren. Habe ich gesehen, am Königssee in Berchtesgaden stand Hackerlschorsch und der war natürlich eine absolute Lokallegende da, weil der hat Gold geholt. Und das war die erste berühmte, da war ich irgendwie keine Ahnung. Aber war es dann nicht auch so, ja, Gold im Schlittenfahren? Ja, aber ich dachte mir auch, der steht da so und der kann halt, und da dachte ich mir, wow, der kann richtig schnell Schlitten fahren. Gerade nicht. Gerade ist er einfach nur ein Typ, der da steht mit einer Mütze auf. Ja, aber er kann, er könnte die Mütze tragen beim Schlitten fahren und es würde nichts an der Zeit ändern. Das ist so bei mir die ganze Zeit, er könnte ihm jetzt nicht zuschauen, der hat schon drei Bier im Toast, der könnte jetzt runterfahren und vielleicht ist er schneller, vielleicht, wenn der Wind gut steht. Ja, ist schon so schwer, aber ich dachte mir, ich war so Starstruck, da war ich wirklich Starstruck. Kann man sich mal die Spitze erstrecken. Ich finde, die besten Roder der Welt, macht mal was Gemeines, zieht mal eine Mütze auf, so eine, macht mal irgendwie, oder so eine, oder fahr rückwärts, fahrt mal rückwärts, weil ihr habt eh alles erreicht, jetzt guck mal was passiert. M Mache Salto, mache Salto. Wie uncool ist es ja, wie schlimm ist es schon, super erfolgreich zu sein, super jung und irgendwie der beste Stabhochspringer zu sein mit 23. Ich meine, was willst du da noch erreichen in deinem Leben? Weil das kannst du ja jetzt, du bist 23. Wie viele Töterverlor hast du als der beste Stabhochspringer der Welt? Ja, und deswegen, dann mach doch mal sowas, weil was soll denn noch passieren in deinem Leben? Ist doch die Besten, dann könnt ihr noch in die Geschichtsbücher eingehen, indem ihr jetzt mal einfach, macht euch mal so Blei an die Füsse. Ja, oder nimm die Stange und mach ganz viel Anlauf und dann spring aber nicht hoch, sondern ramm die Stange einfach dem Schiedsrichter so direkt rein. Einfach so mit von der Hohen. Und dann wärme ich ja bei den Gladiatoren. Und dann holen wir einen Löwen mit rein. Und dann rammt den Schiedsrichter auf den Boden und springt dann noch so drüber. Alles klar. Dass der dann noch ins Publikum springt und sich feiern lässt. Bringt einen Löwen mit rein und kämpft mit der Riesenstange gegen Löwen. Genau, und dann, oh nein, Löwe im Publikum, der hat es eingefädelt. Oh nein, der Löwe ist im Verzug, der läuft Gefahr, den Schiedsrichter zu zermalben. Und der Schwerwerfer. Der Schwerwerfer, zack, trifft nicht. Und dann der Frisbeewerfer, Discos, Diskwerfer, zack. Werbung. Hey, Leute, ihr habt Glück, denn hier bei uns erfahrt ihr es als allererstes. Es gibt bald... Psst, komm mal alles zusammen. Hey, hey, hey, komm mal kurz her. Komm mal kurz her. Laura, auch du. Hey, komm mal her. Nee, nee, komm mal richtig ran jetzt hier. Es gibt bald auf Disney-Plus eine neue Serie und nicht irgendeine Serie, sondern eine Serie aus dem Marvel-Universum, aus dem Avengers-Universum. Völlig richtig, eine Live-Action-Serie, WandaVision. Ich freue mich wahnsinnig drauf, ich glaube, es wird super lustig, ich glaube, es wird mega spannend. Der Cast ist fantastisch, Elizabeth Austin, Paul Bettany. Und wir können sogar schon mal ein bisschen reinhören. Wanda und Vision, sind wir nicht ein schönes Paar? Ab dem 15. Januar geht's los auf Disney Plus. Das ist jetzt unser Zuhause, ich will, dass wir da reinpassen. Unbedingt abonnieren, genau wie das Podcast-Sofo. Und jetzt viel Spaß mit der Folge. Ja, okay. Hey, wir können nicht Werbung für uns auch machen. Das guckt er mit den Schultern. Bin ich tot? Nein, warum denkst du das? Weil du es bist. Werbung Toll, crispy. Typisch ich. Auch so einen Blick in die Kamera. Nur der Kopf aber, weil der Rest ist abgesäbelt worden. Nee, aber das denke ich mir wirklich so, dann fahr mal rückwärts, wirklich. Das sieht euch mal einfach so ein, ich weiß nicht, so ein Onesie an, also so ein Schlaffanzug. Ich glaube, es hat hier angefangen, dass du zuerst sagst, wer kann am schnellsten Schlittschuh fahren. Und dann hat einer gesagt, ich bin so viel schneller als ich, ich mache ein Salto. Und dann hat er gesagt, ja, dann macht ihr euer eigenes Ding, Eiskunstler auch so. Die machen nur noch Scheiß irgendwie, weil sie so schnell, der macht halt immer so Pirouetten und Salty, während er dann irgendwie schneller ist als alle anderen. Während die anderen noch geradeaus fahren. Genau, während die anderen nicht hinterherkommen und hecheln und ausrutschen und ganz dumm wie so ein Hund auf Eis da so versuchen, klarzukommen,
während der da irgendwie
so rückwärts
Schlüssel fährt und noch ein Eis
ist, ein Kalippo währenddessen, hat der gesagt,
komm, dann macht ihr euch eines. Zu Stravinsky,
muss man halt auch mal sagen. Ja. Und die anderen können
nicht mal zu Calcia Candela gerade
ausfahren im Halboval.
So ist Eiskunstlauf entstanden.
So ist Eiskunstlauf entstanden. Ja. Und jetzt ist es belacht. Ist es belächelt? Begrinst. Naja, also I, Tonya habe ich gerne gesehen. Das fand ich schon cool. Das war ein toller Film. Wie die da rumfahren. I, Tonya und Jurassic Park. Oh ja, das finde ich richtig gut. So ein ganz unpassender Protagonist. Ich bin die beste Eiskunstläuferin der Welt. Schnell, die Dinosaurer brechen aus! Ich bin wirklich eine Top-Athletin, Nummer eins der Welt. Auf Eis. Aber da kann ich jetzt halt ... Da kann ich wirklich gar nichts ... sorry, da kann ich nichts mehr ... Aitonia im Alten Testament hätte wirklich gar nichts beizutragen. Nichts beizutragen gehabt. Weit und breit kein Eis, alles voller Wüste, nichts. Genauso wie Magnus Carlsen. Leute, Schach wurde noch nicht erfunden. Ich bin hier völlig, also wirklich, ich krieg hier nichts auf die Reihe, gar nichts. Da steht ein Turm. Ach Gott. Schade.
Komm, setz dich auf deinen Springer und wir reiten gehen Osten.
Wogegen der Diskuswerfer?
Ich glaube, die Leute, die am meisten an Zeitreisen glauben, sind Speerwerfer und Diskuswerfer. Weil stell dir vor, weil heute, ich glaube, so der damals antike beste Diskuswurf war so 16 Meter und heute werfen die so 80 Meter oder sowas. Die hätten die locker an die Wand gespielt damals. Ja klar, wenn ich eine Zeitreise wüsste, in fünf Jahren gibt es Zeitreise, würde ich auch sagen, ich werfe jetzt die Disken durch die Gegend, um dann die einfach zu dominieren. Und dann sagen die, das ist ja unfair, die kommen hier, die sind doppelt so groß wie wir und werfen die doppelt so weit wie wir, weil die so viel Nährstoffe haben. Weil wir uns besser ernähren. Weil wir den ganzen Tag Sand essen. Ganz im Ernst, wenn du jetzt anfangen würdest, dir, keine Ahnung, Diskus draufzuschaffen, Bogen schießen und so, du wärst trotzdem der Schlechteste damals. Der Schlechteste? Nein. Wenn du jetzt anfangen würdest, fünf Jahre from now, du reist dann in die Zeit, hast fünf Jahre geübt, Diskus zu werfen. Aber habe ich auch einen modernen Bogen oder muss ich dann mit dem Holzbogen von damals? Holzbogen? Nee. Na gut, du bist da einen modernen Bogen, wo so groß irgendwie noch, keine Ahnung, Doktor Oetker draufsteht. Das ist eine Gottheit, das ist unser Gott. Der Gott der Nahrung, der sorgt dafür, dass wir immer satt sind. Aber irgendwie macht OE mehr her als Ö, oder? Ja. Schau dir Goethe an oder Dr. Oetker. Ja, ich finde Goethe mit Ö geschrieben. Das wäre total albern. Ich glaube, OE macht echt wirklich generell mehr her. Ich glaube, wenn ich einen Namen hätte mit Ö, ich würde versuchen, das irgendwie auf O-E hinzukriegen. Es macht mehr her. Es wirkt irgendwie edler. Hohecker. Oh, das ist spannend, weil er hat ja die, man weiß nicht mehr, wie es heißt. Höcker. Hohecker. Hohecker. Das ist er Höcker? Nein, weil er die beiden Punkte auf dem E hat. Wie heissen die hier nochmal? Das ist diese Umlaut.
The Umlaut.
It's what they call an Umlaut.
Nein. Punkte auf E.
Der hat Bernhard Hohecker. Ein Trämer.
Bernhard Hohecker hat Punkte auf dem E.
Ja.
Der hat keine Haare, aber Punkte auf dem E.
Es ist sein fucking Ernst.
Ja, Hohecker.
Und Hohecker durchs O hat er so einen diagonalen Strich.
Ja, darüber redet er aber nicht so gern.
Und statt dem E hat er eine Drei.
So schreibt man Hohecker?
Das ist nicht dein Ernst.
Doch.
Zeig mal.
Also das E ist ein Trämer.
Ja, aber gib mal Bernhard Hohecker ein. Du hast doch einen kompletten Schaden, als ob Bernhard Hohecker ein Sonderzeichen im Namen hätte. Bernhard. Bernhard oder Bernhard? Da. What the f? Das habe ich ja noch nie gesehen. Ja, natürlich ist ein Tremor, das wäre ja Höcker. Verstehst du das nicht? Bernhard Hohecker hat wirklich über dem E zwei Punkte. Ja, natürlich. Das ist ja unfassbar. Ich finde, dass er in seiner Freizeit gern Geocaching betreibt. Viel spannender. Muss das im Wikipedia-Artikel stehen? Ich bin hin und weg. Bernhard Hohecker. Und die Lautsprache hat ein Fragezeichen. Das ist auch immer die Lautsprache, die genau sagt, wie er das auch nicht machen will. Und da ist ein Frageze drin. Eckige Klammern, keine Ahnung, wir wissen es nicht. 20. März. Das ist ja unglaublich. Naja, ich finde das nicht unglaublich. Doch, das ist unglaublich. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es Teil der deutschen Sprache ist, dieses Buchstabe. Ja, ich kann es auch, du kannst es benutzen als Wort. Aber wo taucht es denn noch auf? Kannst du aufhören, es als mystisches Etwas zu bezeichnen?
Mach mal Barbara Schöneberger.
Nein.
Nee, mach mal Barbara Schöneberger.
Die heisst nicht Schoeneberger.
Wenn die Schoeneberger so heißen würde, hätte sie Doppelpunkt über dem E.
Mach mal Karolin Kippekus.
Kippekus.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich jetzt alle deutschen Comedians eingehe.
Ja, vielleicht hat die irgendwie so einen Haken auf dem Zeh oder so. Mach mal Annette Frier.
Frier hat nix. Sonst wäre sie Frier.
Schätze, dass alle deutschen Sat.1 Comedians so wilde Sonderzeichen haben.
Kebekus.
Vielleicht auch.
Was war der erste Promille, den du gesehen hast? Der erste, wo du wirklich sagst, der erste berühmte Mensch, wo du gesagt hast, oh, weil mittlerweile sind wir abgehärtet, wir haben mittlerweile alles gesehen, wir haben jeden gesehen, Heinz Strunk haben wir gesehen, wir haben Rokko Schamoni haben wir gesehen, alle, die ganzen grossen Namen haben wir gesehen. Aber primär die beiden, muss man sagen. Aber auch sehr häufig. Aber also, um jetzt mal
nur zwei zu nennen, die beiden haben wir gesehen,
aber auch noch viele mehr. Ja, nur zwei zu nennen.
Aber, wer war bei dir?
Ich weiß es nicht, ehrlich gesagt.
Djokovic, der Joker.
Dirk Djokovic? Nee, Djokovic,
der Tennisspieler, der Joker,
der lange jetzt Platz eins war.
Damals war er noch nicht so erfolgreich, bei den Gary Weber Open
war ich.
Ich muss ein bisschen langsamer sprechen, ich komme kaum hinterher, als ich Tennisspieler. Tennisspieler, der Joker. Ach stimmt, du hast ja auch Tennis gespielt, ne? Ja, wir waren bei den Gary-Weber Open und da war der, hat gespielt, war aber noch nicht so wahnsinnig bekannt. Novak Djokovic ein fantastischer Tennisspieler, der mittlerweile lange auf Platz eins, ich weiß nicht, ist er noch Platz eins der Weltrennistischen, ich glaube nicht, aber er war lange und damals nicht, damals war er so in den Top 20 der Welt. Also er stand neben mir bei so einem Brezelstand, aber dass wir beide Sportler gesehen haben, ist ja spannend. Und dann hast du dir eine Brezel geholt? Beworfen, ich habe die mit Brezel beworfen. Du hast extra eine heiße Brezel gekauft, um die ihm ins Gesicht zu werfen. Ein bisschen unangenehm, weil das war ja sehr unangenehm, wo er aus Wut einen Ball weggeschlagen hat und genau, ich glaube, die Kehle eines Ballmädchens getroffen hat, also die Linienrichterin oder sowas, die dann ins Krankenhaus müssen. Dann hat er das Spiel die Runde verloren. Und es war glaube ich
das Halbfinale oder sowas von den French Open
oder sowas. Moment, er wurde dann disqualifiziert?
Er wurde disqualifiziert, ja.
Weil er aus Wut einen Ball ins Publikum geschlagen hat,
weggeschlagen hat, also hinter
sich und dann Linienrichterin genau getroffen
hat und dann ist sie umgekippt.
Und das darf sie nicht machen.
Und dann wurde er tatsächlich
ein guter Schuss.
Ja, man denkt, es geht jetzt darum um den besten Tenn Tennisspieler. Und er hat ja schon fantastisch getroffen. Ist es nicht ein bisschen unfair, den jetzt... Aber man müsste fragen, wollten Sie denn die treffen? Und dann so einen Lügendetektor. Weil wenn er sagt, nein, dann kann er nicht Tennisspielen. Nee. Aber das ist schon echt ganz, ganz ungünstig. Schöner Tag, Brezel stand, Stefan Thiel zu Brezel in der Hand und BATZ!
Und dann stand neben mir Nowak Djokovic.
Das muss aber zum Thema Speer werfen, da muss es doch regelmäßig passieren, oder?
Dass da jemand einfach so aufgespießt wird von so einem Speer.
Finde ich gefährlich.
Welcher Sportler bist du am besten? Ich glaube, ich bin gar nicht so schlecht im Badminton. Also, ja, ich weiß. Klar, da kannst du jetzt, ich sehe die Mundwinkel, heben sich gen Norden, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Ich kann mir deine fiesen Sprüche auch selber denken. Aber hast du so ein kurzes Höschen auch an? Ich habe ein kurzes Höschen an, natürlich, klar, wenn ich da irgendwie auch mal schön in die Hocke gehe, kann man vielleicht mehr sehen, als man gekommen ist. Weil die Mode ist, finde ich auch immer so interessant, dass man sich bei manchen Sportarten entscheidet, nicht sexy zu sein. Ja. Dass Sexiness nicht an erster Stelle steht. Nee, Sexiness ist Beachvolleyball vorbehalten. Die kriegen alle Sexiness der ganzen Sportwelt ab. Nee, aber ich finde auch so, Fussballer sehen da schnittig aus. Das ist ja ein gutes Outfit einfach so. Diese grossen bunten Stutzen, diese schneidigen engen Schüchen, dann diese Knöchel, die zu... Dann diese... Die Fahne hinten so am Rücken. Nee, aber auch die Trikots sind cool geschnitten und so. Ich finde, Fussballer sind hot. Aber man kann es ja glaube ich auch... Je besser die Uniform aussehen, desto mehr Geld hat der Sport, oder? Ja,
kann sein, weil bei Badminton-Spielern
habe ich noch nie gedacht, holisch.
Weil die haben diese engen, weiten,
sehr weiten Höschen,
sehr kurz, also
alles an Material ist in die Breite
geflossen, dann haben die diese
grossen Werbungen, aber auch
Handballer, ganz schlechte Trikots,
immer grosse, unpassende
Werbungen drauf, gross
AOK. Was das jetzt
Vielen Dank. grossen Werbungen, aber auch Handballer, ganz schlechte Trikots, immer grosse, unpassende Werbungen drauf, gross AOK. Was ist das jetzt so und dann, ich weiß nicht genau, also ich finde manche Sportler haben sich einfach dagegen entschieden, irgendwie cool auszusehen. Bei manchen geht es sehr viel darum. Aber ich glaube, das ist auch eine Illusion, also ich habe dann auch mal Bandmitten gespielt, irgendwie, das war dann, also da sind schon auch Träume zerbrochen, aber irgendwie glaube ich immer noch. Also das war damals zu die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse im Leben von, als wir irgendwie alle in Köln waren für ein paar Wochen und die ganzen Sketche gedreht haben. Da hat man mal so in der Crew oder den Schauspielern gesagt, hey, lass uns heute Abend mal Bandmitten spielen gehen. Und ich dachte mir, die werden mal sehen, worauf sie sich hier eingelassen haben. Die werden mich nicht mehr belächeln ab morgen. und ja, die haben mich halt komplett in die Wand gespielt. Und dann lag ich halt irgendwie röchelnd am Boden irgendwie und habe mir die Knöchel verstaucht. Und ja, ich bin dann nicht mehr gekommen, aber trotzdem dachte ich irgendwie so, denke ich immer noch, ich bin ganz gut. Das ist so ein hartnäckiger Glaube. Das bleibt. Ich glaube, ich müsste häufiger, ich habe mir letztens auch gedacht, ich muss, glaube ich, mal so richtig stürzen.
Also mal so richtig, weil ich mache viele Dinge falsch, ich bin kein gutes Vorbild.
Zum Beispiel, ich mache meine Post nicht auf.
Und dann liegt da irgendwie so.
Du meinst, dem muss mal was passieren.
Ja genau, ich muss mal irgendwie so, Herr Will, Sie haben einfach seit sechs Jahren keine Steuern gezahlt, Privatinsolvenz, ich muss mal so rock bottom treffen, weil sonst lerne ich es auch nicht. Warum denn du? Weil du siehst mich ja damit rein. Ich hänge ja damit zusammen. Wir sind ja der Gesellschafter. Aber das ist so, dann mache ich meine Post nicht auf und dann überfliegt es so. Ich bin letztens, also ich mache es generell so, ich kriege Post, mache ich erst mal nicht auf. Die lege ich erst mal hin, die muss erst mal in der Woche so einfinden. So wie ein guter Wein. Genau, die muss erst mal reifen. Dann wird die Post geöffnet, ich überfliege den Brief mit nur einem Ziel, und zwar suche ich nach einem Datum, nicht nach Inhalt, sondern nur nach einem Datum mit dem, wenn sie nicht bis zum, dann lese ich das Datum, denke ich, auch geil, bis dahin habe ich Zeit, leg den Brief wieder weg. Und am Tag vor diesem, an diesem Tag vor diesem Datum, nehme ich den Brief nebeneinander, sondern wollen wir uns mal angucken, was das ist. Nie denkst du doch an dieses Datum. Ja doch, ich habe das schon im Hinterkopf. Im Hinterkopf oder im Hinter-to-do? Nee, nee, ich habe es im Hinterkopf und dann schaue ich mir den Brief an und dann sage, wenn sie bis zu dem Tag keinen Brief geschrieben haben, dann sind sie nicht mehr versichert. Bringen müssen wir sie umbringen. Dann müssen wir leider in beide Beine und einen der beiden Arme brechen. Und dann bitte kreuzen Sie an, welchen... Bitte markieren Sie vorher bis zum 23.10. Welche Gliedmassen wir Ihnen brechen sollen. Sonst sehen wir uns leider gezwungen, in der Rechten zu nehmen. Genau. Und da hieß es jetzt so, ja, schicken Sie uns einen Brief oder eine DE-Mail. Eine was-Mail? Eine DE-Mail. Und ich dachte, ja, kein Problem. Wir leben noch nicht, weil es für eine DE-Mail. Das ist anscheinend so eine super offizielle Mail, die man auch behördlich nutzen kann, damit Behörden wissen, okay, das ist irgendwie legit, das ist nicht einfach nur irgendein Spammer. Kann man nicht wichtig in den Betreffschreiben? Entweder das oder halt eine DE-Mail. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich mal recherchiert, das Konzept DE-Mail, und zwar muss da jemand bei dir, zu Hause kommt da jemand vorbei, klopft an, herein. Und guckt dir beim Mailschreiben zu, richtig? Genau. Und muss verifizieren, dass du die Mail tatsächlich geschrieben hast. Und dann ist sie gehört. Nee, der muss einmal bei dir klopfen und verifizieren, dass du tatsächlich da wohnst, wo du angegeben hast, dass du wohnst. Also der guckt bei dir zum Fenster rein.
Kann man dem nicht einen Brief mitgeben dann?
Weil da ist doch schon immer jemand da.
Ja.
Der kann auch auf dem Weg, ist doch im Briefkasten.
Der guckt dann bei dir rein, verifiziert dich und ab dann kannst du dir e-mails.
Das ist der grösste Quatsch, den ich jemals gehört habe.
Das klingt so wenig effizient.
Ja, das ist eine absolute Horrorvorstellung.
Und da habe ich mich dann angemeldet und dachte mir, mein Gott, okay, ich muss diesen Brief heute schreiben, sonst fliege ich da raus,
aus was auch immer. Altenkrankenversicherung,
was auch immer. Irgendwas halt,
langes Wort. Und dann
heißt so, ja, sie werden angerufen,
um einen Termin
zu vereinbaren, wann jemand bei ihnen
vorbeikommen kann. Also wirklich so
Horror hoch drei. Sie werden angerufen, damit jemand einen Termin vorbeikommt, dass jemand bei ihnen vorbeikommen kann. Also wirklich so Horror hoch drei.
Sie werden angerufen, damit jemand einen Terminvereinbar kommt, dass jemand bei Ihnen vorbeikommt. Da dachte ich mir, ja, ist sie kein Problem. Und dann hat tatsächlich jemand von mir angerufen. Also wirklich die zwielichtigste Gestalt aller Zeiten. Der klang, als würde er 30 Meter vom Telefonhörer entfernt sitzen. Also wie gesagt, ich tippe mal lokal, einfach mal Nähe Neu-Delhi. auch ruft dann an und sagt, ja, guten Tag, die E-Mail, Termin für die Verifikation. Ich habe mir, ja geil, komm heute vorbei, ich muss heute noch die Mail schreiben. Und er so, ja, frühester Termin ist März. Das Konzept der E-Mail ist gerade von wow, geil, vielleicht was Gutes, hin zu, das ist die bescheuertste Idee der ganzen Welt.
Ja, und dann habe ich mir auch gesagt, was glauben Sie denn, wer ich
bin? Glauben Sie, ich muss eine wichtige
Mail schreiben und melde mich zwei
Monate davor? Also,
wie soll das für mich denn? Habe ich auch gesagt, komm, lassen Sie das
stundieren. Gut, da kann Sanji jetzt ja auch nichts dafür aus Indien
wahrscheinlich. Ja, gut. Der ist mit dir, der telefonieren muss,
leider Gottes. Und dann habe ich gesagt, stundieren Sie den
ganzen Quatsch und der, okay, dann stundieren wir, also als wäre das regelmäßig vorkommen, studieren wir.
Und ja, ich habe mal wieder mich in die Sackgasse manövriert.
Aber die E-Mail hat nicht funktioniert.
Spannende Sache, aber da sind wir genau diametral auseinander, wirklich.
Weil ich möchte alle Tasks sofort erledigen.
Wenn was reinkommt, also wenn ihr mir eine Mail schreibt und ihr kriegt nicht in den ersten zehn Sekunden Nacherhalt eine Antwort, kriegt ihr nie eine Antwort. Das ist bei mir so. Ich antworte sofort auf Mails. Ich habe mittlerweile ein sehr komplexes Markierungssystem. Wenn eine wichtige Mail reinkommt, dann sehe ich, ah, die ist wichtig, ich markiere sie mit der roten Fahne und dann wird sie vergessen. Wenigstens hat sie die rote Fahne. Sie hat die rote Fahne
bekommen, aber das hilft ihr halt auch
nichts. Irgendwie so eine Million ungeöffnete
Mails in deinem, das ist halt diese
rote Punkt, wo ich immer dachte,
der kann maximal einstellig sein,
ist bei dir ja schon fünfstellig.
Nee, das ist Quatsch.
Aber tatsächlich hat es bis jetzt immer noch
irgendwie geklappt. Dann ruft man an und
sagt, sorry, und dann ja, dann klappt es schon.
Ich glaube, ich muss mal wirklich so,
dass ich eines Tages irgendwie
Und dann, einfach um die eine Lektion zu schlagen. Ich habe den Versehrungsbeitrag nicht gezahlt. Ja, habe ich nicht darauf reagiert. Du brauchst einen Schlägertrupp mit so Baseballschlägern, die mal in deine Wohnung kommen,
und mal alles kaputt schlagen, einfach um die eine Lektion zu schlagen. Wir haben den Versicherungsbeitrag nicht gezahlt, dann schlagen die da irgendwie meinen Beamer ein.
Und sie müssen nie unterschreiben, dass wir alles kaputt gemacht haben.
Und dann kriegst du so eine Mail, waren sie zufrieden mit dem AOK Einschüchterungsservice.
Ja, also.
Wehe ist da, Einschüchterungsservice, ja kommen Sie rein Ja, kommen Sie rein. Ist es okay, wenn wir das kaputt machen? Bam! Und dann ist auch die Frage, war man zufrieden damit jetzt? Schwierig. Schwierig, was muss man da sagen. Er hat vorher gefragt, was er kaputt machen kann. Am Anfang sehr eingeschüchtert, aber als er dann am Ende irgendwie bei mir ein Stück Kuchen genommen hat und gefragt hat, ob er aufs Flo gehen kann noch kurz,
gefragt hat, ob er die Schuhe ausziehen soll, habe ich mir gedacht, naja, muss das sein.
Also wie eingeschüchtert waren sie, da kann man so einen großen, so einen Smiley mit offenem Mund und den Smiley mit so einem Gän in den Emoji. Ja, ja. Ne, also das, vielleicht passiert das noch irgendwie wirklich mal der komplette Absturz in Verschuldung, Verpfändung, ja, auch sowas, dass mal jemand kommt und was pfändet, das könnte, glaube ich, nochmal so ein Wachrütteln für mich sein.
Aber das heisst, also wenn ich jetzt angenommen, wir wären zusammen, wir hätten eine GbR und wir teilen uns die Einnahmen, die wir unter anderem durch diesen Podcast generieren, sei es durch Merch-Verkäufe oder aber auch durch Tour-Einnahmen. Und es ist ja so, dass ich ja jetzt der verantwortliche Finanzguru bin. Nur weil dein Name als erster auf der GbR steht, heisst das nicht, dass du irgendwelche Sonderrechte hast? Heisst das denn, dass du gar nicht kontrollierst, ob du genau die Hälfte bekommst? Nö. Ehrlich zu sein, immer wenn du mit mir über diese GbR redest und so, dann kommt irgendwie so ein Wasserfallrauschen in meinem Kopf. Es wird immer lauter, immer lauter. Und dann schaue ich nur noch auf deinen Mund und versuche Pausen abzupassen, um zu nicken. Aber wie bei 2001, wo der Roboter wie heißt der nochmal? Hell. Hellshock 2000. 2000. So klingt das. Schön auch. Herzlich. Beißes Rauschen. Ja, so ein richtig starkeriger, so ein reissender Wasserfall, so kurz vorm Dammbruch, das finde ich immer am entspannendsten. Tatsächlich, ich kann manchmal nicht einschlafen und denke mir so, was sind spannende Szenarien und dann denke ich mir immer, nee, das ist gefährlich, irgendwie immer so eine leere Wiese, da könnte irgendwie so ein Stier auf mich zugaloppieren. Ich glaube, ich bin zu ängstlich, selbst in meinen Gedanken. Du hast selbst Angst vor der Schafsherde, die du zählen musst. Dass ich dann irgendwie mich verzählte, aber dann, oh scheiße, kann ich nochmal, ah fuck du, nee nee, du du du, geh nochmal zurück, geh nochmal, ah fuck jetzt, wie viel habe ich schon? Och, und dann muss ich nochmal von vorne anfangen. Und dann kannst du so eine Spraydose nehmen und einfach gross Eins draufschreiben. Wie hat sich das durchgesetzt, Schäfchen zählen als Einschlafen ist das fucking stressigste, was ich mir überhaupt nur vorstellen kann. Du musst einen Haufen Dinger zählen, die alle gleich aussehen. Durcheinander laufen alle. Durcheinander laufen. Die ganze Zeit ist irgendwo ein wilder Hund, der nur darauf wartet, dich aufzuzerfleischen. Ist es dann Tag oder Nacht bei dir, wenn du Schäfchen zählst? Wenn. Eigentlich Tag. Bei mir ist es Echt Nacht? Und dann schlafen die da was? Und du gehst durch die Reine? Nee, die hopsen über einen Zaun. Aber jetzt mal ganz kurz. Da ist ein Zaun in der Mitte. Laden sich Schafe elektrisch auf, wenn die sich... Wenn du an den Reifst? Wenn sich so zwei Schafe nebeneinander laufen, laden die sich... Nee, die sind ja nicht aus Polyester. Die sind ja hundertprozentig Schafsrolle.
Ah ja, okay. Und das war bisher gar nichts.
Aber Katzen oder nicht?
Unser Physiklehrer hatte immer so eine Katzenfell, um irgendwas statisch aufzuladen.
Was?
Laden sich dann Katzen auf?
Ja, die laden sich ganz doll auf.
Entladen die sich mit zu Blitzen.
Checken Tiere, was ein Stromschlag ist, oder denken die, was zur Hölle war das denn? Entschuldigung, nee, ich glaube, die checken das, die wissen es genau. Keine Ahnung, ich denke mir immer, auch Jurassic Park, die Raptoren haben die Zäune angegriffen, strategisch, um sie nach Schwachstellen zu untersuchen, machen das Kühe auch auf so einer Kuhweide. Klar, Kühe planen, glaube ich, die ganzen Tage im Ausbruch. Nee, den ganzen Tag.
Weil was machen sie sonst den ganzen Tag? Das wäre die andere Gegenfrage. Gegenfrage, was machen sie sonst den ganzen Tag? Die blicken sich, die geben sich immer so verschwörerische Blicke und dann so ein leichtes Nicken. Und dann Nachfliege, damn, damn it, das hat mich für eine Fliege genervt. Du kannst mal ruckartig bewegen. Wie geht's denen eigentlich? Das frage ich mich häufig. Ich habe auch jetzt neulich meinen Hund bei mir zu Hause gehabt, weil er eine Freundin mitgebracht hat. Ganz komische Sache. Wesen, ja. So ein Hund. Ganz merkwürdig. Weil was denkt der Hund den ganzen Tag? Der schläft dann auch? Der träumt dann auch? Der hat so ein ganz spezielles kleines Leben. Ja, vor allem der, wenn der, also dann fährt man ja teilweise in Urlaub und der Hund weiss ja nicht, okay, jetzt, oh, die packen jetzt zusammen, jetzt geht's los, wir gehen Gassi oder was und jetzt geht's los und dann fahren die in einem Auto weg und kommen drei Wochen nicht. Dem kann man ja nicht sagen, du pass auf, wir fahren jetzt in Urlaub. Ich habe den, ich habe gar nicht, ich habe den ganzen Termine gar nicht abgesagt. Das geht nicht, ich kann jetzt nicht in Urlaub fahren. Ich kann jetzt nicht drei Wochen weg. Wir können jetzt nicht spontan nach Madagaskar. Ja, der ist immer bereit. So, der ist immer ready. So, der andere zieht sich die Jacke an, der Hund so, nö, ich könnte gehen jetzt. Musst du noch mal kurz? Nö, ich bin jetzt bereit. Wir können jetzt auswandern. Wir können jetzt, I'm totally okay with it. Wir können jetzt gehen und nie wieder zurückkommen. Ja, es wäre mir völlig egal. Ich habe keine Freunde hier, ich habe keine Termine hier, ich schlafe überall, ich brauche nur mich selbst. Ich kann mich in mich selber einrollen und schlafen. Welcher Tag ist heute? I don't fucking ... Wie alt bin ich? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wie lange lebe ich noch? Ja. Wenn nicht auch eine Ahnung. Wie lautet der Anfang dieses Satzes? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wie lange lebe ich noch? Nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung.
Wie lautet der Anfang dieses Satzes? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Bin ich jung, bin ich alt, habe ich noch lange zu leben?
Nicht den Hauch einer?
Ein Eichhörnchen.
Einfach bereit.
Ja, okay.
Okay, los geht's.
Das liegt jetzt im Urlaub, Schatz.
Okay.
Deswegen auch dieses Bailen, dieses Ruh ist ja im Prinzip Ja. Ja, ist es wirklich ja? Ja, die ja sagen jetzt zu allen erstmal ja. Ja, das ist eigentlich die defekten, perfekten Improv, Leute, einfach, ja, yes and. Wir gehen weg, okay? Gibt's einen Film, der ja sage, weil wo würdest, wo, ich glaube, du wärst heute noch im Ausland, wenn du die ganze Zeit ja sagen würdest. Wenn du jetzt ab heute Ausland, keine Ahnung, ja, wenn irgendwer sagt, komm, wir fangen jetzt los nach England und du musst Ja sagen. Aber wer sollte das zu mir sagen? Weiß ich nicht. Ein Obdachloser, du ländst ja komischen Gesprächen oder sowas. Wenn du ab jetzt Ja sagst, den ganzen Abend noch Ja sagst, wenn du gleich eine Mate kaufst, sagst du immer Ja, egal was er sagt.
Ja, okay.
Jetzt muss ja nur einer mal merken,
und dann ist er schon vorbei. Ja, das ist ein Problem.
Würden sie mir auch mehr Geld geben?
Ja.
Dann geben sie mir mehr Geld.
Du musst es machen.
Was glaubst du, würde passieren, wenn du ab jetzt,
wir haben jetzt schon 20 Uhr.
Ich glaube, jetzt ist es egal. Was mache ich jetzt noch? Ich hole mir jetzt noch eine schöne Mate.
Soll ich ihn nicht einpacken? Ja. Wow. Das krasse Sozialexperiment.
Zwei Wochen vorbereitet, Günter Wallraff steht in den Startlöchern, wir sagen einen ganzen Tag lang zu allem Ja. In der Tüte? Cut, er muss so eine Plastiktüte in den Müll werden. Ich glaube, es würde sich gar nichts ändern. Das wäre jetzt wirklich langweilig, Sozialexperiment aller Zeiten. Das ist noch was anderes sein, ja. Was denn? Und dann Schnitt, er hat nur diese eingepackte Mate. Hochrotter Kopf. Das machen ja viele YouTuber so, die machen dann so Sozialexperimente und dann irgendwie so den ganzen Tag Ja sagen und denen geht es noch gut. Ich würde sagen, ihr sagt auch Ja und zwar zum Ende der Folge, zu einer richtig schönen Woche, die wünschen wir euch. Vielen, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, haut rein, nächste Woche sind wir wieder mit dabei, wenn es wieder heisst, Stefan Tietzel, Lährein.
Wenn es wieder heisst, hallo ist ein Podcast-Ofo.
Ja.
Das wird es auch nächste Woche wieder heissen, es gibt ja ein tolles Intro. Ach ja, nochmal den Aufruf, wir brauchen tolle Intros von euch.
Kurz.
Schickt uns gute Intros.
Kurz sollten sie sein.
Ich weiss nicht, warum du das so betonst, schickt uns einfach gute Intros.
Kurz bitte.
Gut, denkt an die Kurzgeschichten und ich wünsche euch eine fantastische Woche, wir heben ab. Ciao.